hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the other
rival schools and we see epictetus
criticizing and criticizing rather
heavily is discourses where what we're
called the academics and the academics
like I put up here are coming from
Plato's Academy which is founded by
Plato the student of Socrates it's one
of the very first philosophical schools
in Athens and is a long and illustrious
history in the course of that history
they eventually veer into skepticism and
skepticism had existed before the
Academy and go on that way you have this
this guy pyro who is the skeptic and
skeptical you know comes from the word
you know school bein which means to look
into to try to examine is it that's a
word that Socrates uses quite a lot and
the skeptics they focused on on
attaining knowledge and in criticizing
claims to have knowledge or you know
claims to have certain knowledge to be
certain about things they you know they
didn't all have exactly the same
position on what we could know and what
we couldn't know
really were focused on gaining knowledge
about what we could doubt and some of
them talked in terms of probability
saying well we can't be really sure
about anything but we can at least speak
with probability about you know things
being a certain way or at least
appearing to be a certain way so the
skeptics are people who who do in fact
want to attain knowledge they value it
very highly but they think that most of
the claims that people make about a
counter knowledge whether these are
histological claims or even ethical
claims are now if we examine them well
founded and the skeptics the academic
skeptics when in the after the stoics
pretty heavily as a matter of fact there
were some important exchanges between
the early stomachs and the academic
skeptics writing back and forth
unfortunately we've lost most of this
but we do know quite a bit about it
through authors like Cicero by the time
of Epictetus the academic skeptics are
well established as a philosophical
movement approach there's there's people
also epictetus is willing to say that
are not directly members of the school
but but sort of you know live out that
kind of life as well and so epictetus
thinks that it's important to look
carefully at what is going on with these
people who are academic skeptics are are
they able to justify sort of positions
that they themselves are taking now he
has to really interesting discussions
about as one is in chapter 5 of book 1
and there he frames it in terms of a
it's called petrification or hardening
to stone yeah doesn't happen within the
body but happens within the soul or the
mind of the person and this is the great
word before Apple these lessness Oh
bleep those sorry you know literally
turning into stone so what is this an
issue
epictetus says that this is turning to
stone is viewed as a good state of
character by the academic skeptics so
the question is is it really a good
state of character if it is then great
they they're onto something if it's not
then this is something wrong with the
position that they're taking is
something wrong with the philosophy as a
way of life that they're pursuing a
patina says there's two main ways that
people end up having this hardening to
stone going on within the soul one
happens within the reasoning faculty or
the mind or the intellect you know
there's different terms that he's using
in the past if she's not trying to
distinguish by the way between these
uses different faculties well you can
think of this is a cognitive problem
right they're not able to follow an
argument that leads somewhere so they
can be skeptical about it I just don't
get it i'm not quite sure about this and
by the way to be see plenty of this in
modern-day philosophy and in many other
places I remember when I was in graduate
school is a little bit with tangent he
was very popular for people to say as a
way of you know trying to tank an
opponent's argument I'm sure I don't
know what you're talking about so
epictetus would say oh you don't know
what the person's talking about well
that's on you that's a problem with your
mind that's not necessarily a problem
with their position or their argument or
their explanation right so not being
able to follow an argument step by step
to understand the argument and most of
all to not see contradictions in the
position that one is actually holding to
be unable to grasp that that sort of
thing he gives as an example of that
there's this interesting set of doubts
about our be asleep and dreaming or army
awake he says do your senses tell you
that you are awake when the skeptic says
know any more than they do it when it
dreams I have the impression I'm awake
then he says to the guy really is there
there no difference between these two
impressions and the guy says no there is
a day and a patina says people like that
you can't reach they have turned to
stone that's not you know your fault you
can't reach them it's their fault they
kept be reached because they have
allowed that to happen to their
intellect he says can I argue with this
man any longer you know what Carter
lancet shall I apply to make him realize
he's dead then there's another kind of
skeptical hardening stone epic distances
of the sense of Sheen and self-respect
so that the person is not moved by
seeing the contradiction and doesn't aim
to overcome the contradiction and
improve themselves so when the person
realizes there's something wrong there's
something missing there's something
inadequate about their reasoning
processes and they don't think that
that's a problem why is why does it have
to do with the sense of shame or
self-respect because a person who does
actually feel something like that would
say oh yeah fix that i would like to
actually be you know consistent or
that's a problem on my part I should try
to develop my intellectual trace how did
I let things go that far well you know
some people including the academic
skeptics as epic uses portraying up they
don't do that in fact they see it as a
good thing they're able to not be you
know tricked were moved by other people
so to go back to the the example of the
guy who can't tell whether he's in a
dream state or whether he's awake
epictetus says he does realize it but
pretends that he does not he's even
worse than a corpse one man does not
notice the contradiction he's in a bad
way to not notice a contradiction that's
a problem another man notices it he's
not moved and does not improved he's a
still worse state his self-respect and
sense of
game have been locked off it is
reasoning faculty has been I will not
say cut away but brutalized take him
down to the level of the animals this is
a very serious set of criticisms that he
is raising their against the academics
he's going to raise some other
interesting criticisms in chapter 20 of
book to basically like I put on the
board here what he's saying is that the
academics are going to use the same true
and evident propositions or principles
that they will then deny when other
people try to use them in order to
establish their position so how does
this happen well abiquiu just tells us
says one way to consider is that perhaps
the strongest proof of a proposition
being evident the fact that even the man
who contradicts it finds himself obliged
at the same time to employ it for
example if a man should contradict the
proposition that there is a universal
statement which is true it's clear he
must assert the contrary and say no
universal statement is true but this is
not true either for what else does this
assertion amount to that if a statement
is universal it is false here's another
example he says a man comes forward and
say I would have any know that nothing
is knowable but everything is uncertain
or somebody else has believed in me and
it will be to your advantage when I say
what not to believe a man at all or
again so what else learn from me man
that it is impossible to learn anything
it is I who tell you this and I will
prove it to you if you wish and epic
Tina says what is going on there right
he says what difference is there between
these people at whom shall I say to
those who call themselves academics Oh
madman say the academics give your
assent to the statement that no man
assets to any statement believe us when
we say no man can believe anything so
Epictetus is criticism here is that the
academics themselves in trying to
undermine knowledge you know ostensibly
for the purpose of purifying it or
finding something
can be absolutely certain about are
actually using the very principles in
propositions that they claim to be
showing you know not to be self-evident
or able to be questionable or any of
those sorts of things and it really
amounts to sort of a claim to authority
on their own part which is liable to
take somebody in whose hand this
hardening to stone but which the stoic
is going to look at and say yeah I'm not
going to buy